hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and after the
biggest battle in the Four Knights of
the Apocalypse manga so far we now know
how strong all four Knights are and we
know how they Stack Up in relation to
each other this battle was absolutely
insane not only did it feature the Four
Knights and their allies fighting former
members of The Ten Commandments and the
main villain King Arthur but even King
meliodas himself joined this battle and
he was almost defeated which is just
crazy the seven deadly sins sequel manga
is really on fire right now so in this
video I will break down the powers and
abilities of all four Knights of the
apocalypse and I will rank them from
weakest to strongest based on all the
information that we have so far you guys
know what to do if you want to see more
seven deadly sins and Four Knights of
the Apocalypse content here on the
channel leave a quick like and comment
right now to help me out with that
YouTube algorithm and I know that the
majority of you guys who watch this
channel are not yet subscribed remember
that if you don't subscribe and click
that Bell to turn on all notifications
you're gonna miss a ton of our videos in
the future that's just how YouTube Works
do me a quick favor and subscribe right
now it's completely free and it helps me
out a lot finally this video will
contain Four Knights of the Apocalypse
manga spoilers I will be using all the
information that we have so far so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned for those who are still new
to the seven deadly sins sequel manga or
who might just be reading casually the
Four Knights of the Apocalypse are 16
year old teenagers who are destined to
have a massive impact on the world of
Britannia at least according to an
important prophecy King Arthur and the
holy Knights of Camelot believe that
these four Knights are destined to
destroy the world and they want to
eliminate them before they have a chance
to bring up about the apocalypse
essentially the Knights of Camelot are
trying to take out the threat before it
becomes a bigger Threat by taking out
the knights while they are still
inexperienced teenagers however the
people of Leones refer to these four
Knights as the Four Knights of Prophecy
and in Leona as the Four Knights are
prophesized to become saviors of the
world not its destroyers the Kingdoms of
Camelot and leonis are currently at War
and their radically different opinion of
the Four Knights reflects their
respective allegiances in Camelot the
Four Knights of the Apocalypse are seen
as enemies and in Leones they are seen
as allies in fact King meliodas went out
of his way to gather all four knights in
leonis and that is exactly where they
are when the big battle against former
Commandments and King Arthur breaks out
now let's get into the rankings it goes
without saying that all four Knights of
Apocalypse are exceptionally strong
compared to the normal inhabitants of
Britannia and they they all have
extremely powerful and interesting
magical abilities that said the weakest
of the Four Knights of the Apocalypse at
this early stage of the story is Gawain
Gawain is the only female member of the
group and she was the last Knight to be
introduced to the story in chapter 58.
according to the prophecy Gawain is the
Knight of famine who possesses gold
colored magic the words gold colored
magic is actually a reference to
Sunshine the divine grace that was
originally possessed by mael and later
inherited by escanor Gawain somehow
inherited the power after escanor died
in the original Seven Deadly Sins manga
although we still don't know how exactly
she came into possession of this power
although they are very different
characters in many ways Gawain and
escanor do share some similarities they
are both cocky and egotistical when they
are in their daytime form their bodies
change drastically depending on the time
of day they both refer to themselves as
the master of the Sun and Gawain uses a
weapon called sacred sword Rita which is
clearly a reference to escanor's Divine
acts Rita even though we don't yet know
how Gawain came to possess Sunshine we
do know that she is the niece of King
Arthur Pendragon this is interesting
since Arthur is the ruler of Camelot and
the main villain of the series so far
and yet Gawain doesn't seem to be loyal
to Arthur or Camelot at some point
Gawain decided to run away from Camelot
and she is now seen as an enemy and a
traitor by King Arthur due to the fact
that she possesses Sunshine Gawain has
absolutely incredible physical power and
she likes to dominate her enemies using
Brute Force Beyond Sunshine Gawain also
possesses incredible magical abilities
which makes her an extremely stacked
fighter in theory she is able to use
strong spells like absolute cancel to
cancel out a Perfect Cue and she can use
Advanced teleportation magic to
instantly teleport from one spot to
another she can also teleport inanimate
objects from one location to another
instantly such as instantly teleporting
a weapon into her opponent's body these
are of course highly Advanced magical
spells and since she is a native of
Camelot where Merlin currently resides I
am inclined to believe that she may have
been personally trained by Merlin at
some point in the past I can't imagine
that a powerful wizard like Merlin
wouldn't be intimately familiar with
someone who possesses both sunshine and
advanced magical techniques like
absolute cancel especially since Gawain
is also a blood relative of King Arthur
and Merlin and Arthur are still close or
at least they appear to be Merlin is
definitely connected to Gawain in some
way we just need to find out how ever
since Arthur was revealed to be a
villain in the story I've been wondering
why Merlin would still be standing by
his side side and seemingly supporting
him in his attempt to eliminate everyone
who isn't human knowing Merlin and the
fact that she herself is not exactly
human this just didn't make sense so
I've been speculating that maybe
Arthur's mind was corrupted by the power
of chaos and Merlin has been secretly
working behind his back in order to stop
him perhaps Merlin trained goane and
then helped her Escape Camelot because
Merlin wants to fulfill the prophecy of
the Four Knights of the Apocalypse since
they might be the only ones who can stop
chaos Arthur we'll have to see if this
Theory pans out but I do think that
there is a secret connection between
Merlin and gawaine that will be revealed
later on in the story now moving on
unfortunately for gawaine even with
sunshine and all those impressive
magical skills she is still the weakest
out of the Four Knights of the
Apocalypse her moves are still too basic
and predictable and she is not a very
skilled or experienced fighter at this
stage in the story even with Sunshine
Gawain can still be defeated by an
experienced holy Knight with Superior
fighting techniques as proven by holding
out of Camelot pelaguard who
successfully takes her down pretty
quickly Gawain is also highly
undisciplined and egotistical especially
the first time we meet her she thinks
that she is the best and the strongest
and she refuses to listen to orders from
anyone even if obeying those orders
would be for her own good after she
loses to pellegard in battle Gawain is
in complete denial and she throws a
tantrum like a child she calms down only
after Tristan gives her a bunch of false
compliments in order to satiate her
raging ego to be fair after her defeat
to pelaguard Gawain does recover and
soon after she fights bravely against
chaoska land and chaos malascula but in
the end she is defeated by them as well
once that happens her massive muscular
body shrinks and she assumes the form of
a small child like girl this small form
is her true form and she was actually
using the power of sunshine to make her
body large and muscular when she
overuses this power as she did in the
fight against galand and malascula she
reverts back to her original form
overall Gawain has a ton of potential
and the combination of possessing
sunshine and being able to use Advanced
magic could make her one of the
strongest characters in the entire
series at some point in the future she's
almost like what would happen if escanor
and Merlin had a daughter which is
something to think about that said
Gawain still has a long way to go in
order to truly Master the power of
sunshine and she is not even close to
the power level of former Sunshine users
Mile and escanor she also has a lot of
work to do when it comes to disciplining
herself and reigning in her own ego
until she makes some serious
improvements in that regard she'll
remain at number four on our list at
number 3 3 we have the main protagonist
of our story Percival Percival is the
first night of the Apocalypse that we
meet at the very beginning and according
to the prophecy he is the Knight of
death he has a very unique appearance as
his hair is green and shaped like a pair
of wings his eyes are purple and he
looks like a 10 year old kid even though
he's actually 16. he also often wears
his Grandpa's big old helmet a helmet
which is clearly too big for his head
and this adds to the uniqueness of his
appearance Percival was raised by his
grandpa in total isolation from the
outside world atop a Giant pillar-shaped
Mountain percival's grandpa is actually
a former Holy Knight of Camelot and he
spent countless hours training a young
person to become a powerful Warrior this
training started when Percival was only
three years old and it ended when
percival's father Ironside another Holy
Night of Camelot suddenly showed up and
killed the percival's grandfather after
that person possible set out on a
journey to avenge his grandpa and so his
isolation from the outside world came to
an abrupt and as Percival Ventures into
the outside world and begins to interact
with other people he slowly begins to
discover and develop his unique magical
abilities Percival possesses a lot more
strength and durability than an ordinary
human in addition Percival seems to have
enhanced resistance against drugs and
other types of potions and he has above
average lung capacity due in part to the
fact that he grew up at a very high
altitude on top of his impressive
physical skills and combat capabilities
things that he developed through many
years of training with his grandpa
Percival also discovers that he
possesses a very rare and unique type of
magic called hope hope is Magic that is
powered by the hope of the user's allies
and by the faith that the Allies place
in the user you know those memes about
the power of friendship in anime and
manga well this is literally that
pellegard believes that hope is an
extremely rare type of magic known as
hero type magic which manifests in only
a very small number of people hope magic
enables Percival to generate a magical
Aura around his body or parts of his
body and he can then manipulate that
aura in a variety of different ways for
example the magical Aura allows him to
defend himself by acting as his shield
and reducing the damage from enemy
attacks it also enhances his own
physical strength when he is the one
doing the attacking and it can even heal
a life-threatening injuries almost
instantly the aura can also assume
different shapes and forms such as
turning itself into a pair of wings and
allowing Percival to literally fly on
top of that Holt magic can absorb the
magic attacks of others and shoot them
back at the attacker and Percival is
also able to use hope magic to create a
bunch of Chibi clones these chibi clones
have a will of their own and they assist
Percival whenever he finds himself in a
tough spot the Clones also have the
ability to heal percival's injuries and
the injuries of his allies and as
powerful and versatile as all of these
magic powers are we're not even done yet
there is still more to percival's powers
and abilities for example he possesses
the ability to instantly drain all the
fluid out of a living being just by
touching the person directly basically
mummifying that part of the person's
body that Percival had come into direct
contact with Percival first demonstrated
this ability when he was in a state of
extraordinary agitation and despair as
he falsely believed that his friends had
just been killed normal healing magic
cannot even reverse the effects of this
strange mummification not even goddess
healing magic can reverse it and so only
percival's own hope magic seems capable
of reversing its effects interestingly
enough Percival is able to speak the
language of demon although no one seems
to know why not even Percival we still
don't know who percival's mother is by
the way and this might be a hint that
Percival may not be just an ordinary
human and that he may be of mixed race
Heritage like maybe he is part demon
we'll have to wait and see anyway
Percival currently possesses the
legendary sword Dragon handle which once
belonged to meliodas Dragon handle is
also one part of the coffin of Eternal
darkness which is something we learned
back in the original Seven Deadly Sins
Series this once Broken Sword was
repaired and turned into a fully
functioning sword by Hauser and Percival
has now learned to use hope magic to
enhance the power of the sword as the
main character in the story and the guy
with literally the power of Friendship
on his side Percival has the most
potential out of anyone to become the
strongest character in the entire manga
but at this point in time he still lacks
experience as a holy night and he is
still learning to understand and control
his magic while Percival still has more
self-control than Gawain does and for
that reason he would probably defeat her
in battle he still doesn't have the
combat experience and Technical skill
that Tristan and Lancelot possess and
for that reason he remains at number
three on our list at number two we have
the son of meliodas and Elizabeth and
the prophesies the Knight of pestilence
Prince Tristan when he appears in
chapter 54 of the sequel manga Tristan
is already an experienced holy Knight
and he has a platoon of holy nights
under his command this platoon has a
very original name by the way the
Tristan platoon we know that Tristan has
been exceptionally strong and skilled in
combat ever since he was a child and
what really makes him unique is the fact
that he inherited both goddess and demon
powers from his parents this makes him a
special kind of creature in the world of
the seven deadly sins and its sequel on
Nephilim Tristan is even able to
manifest both demon and goddess Powers
at the same time which is something that
we haven't seen since the days of my l
slash Esther Rosa and even then Tristan
is still different because unlike mael
Tristan is literally the child of one of
the strongest demons and one of the
strongest goddesses in history it's
interesting to note that Tristan uses
two swords in battle one sword is black
and the other is white in one of the
question Corners author nakabasuzuki
revealed that Tristan's two swords are
actually named mael and Esther Rosa
Tristan has access to goddess magic such
as summoning large angelic wings that
allow him to fly using unbelievably
powerful healing abilities and using
other standard goddess powers like Ark
most of the time Tristan prefers to rely
on his goddess Powers alone but when he
is pushed to the point where he can't
win by using only goddess powers he is
able to tap into his demon side when he
Taps into his demonic Powers Tristan's
eyes turned black and a large demon Mark
appears on his forehead this demon mode
makes Tristan a lot more powerful but
it's also much harder to turn off and to
control in this form Tristan kind of
goes berserk and he makes rash and risky
decisions that he would not have made
otherwise for example demon mode Tristan
tries to fight King Arthur head on
despite clear warnings that he still
isn't strong enough to defeat him and
then Tristan's father meliodas is forced
to intervene and risk his own life in
order to protect his son from Arthur I
believe that Tristan and his demon mode
is clearly stronger than Percival and
Gawain at this point in time for example
once he awakens his demon mode Tristan
is able to easily destroy the fusion of
melascula and galand even though no one
on the battlefield was able to do any
significant damage to them before that
and that includes Percival and going but
it is clear that Tristan still hasn't
mastered his demon mode and that he has
a long way to go before he reaches his
full potential in fact he actively
avoids using his demon mode because he
knows that he can't control it and he
knows that this mode makes him act out
in ways that are both abnormal and
dangerous
because he is the son of one of the
strongest goddesses and one of the
strongest demons in history and because
he possesses the ability to use both
demon and goddess Powers at the same
time Tristan has absolutely incredible
potential and he is definitely a
contender for becoming one of the
strongest characters in the entire
series at some point in the future but
for now we know that he isn't the
strongest Knight of the Apocalypse
because Tristan himself confirms it in
chapter 80 of the manga speaking
directly to Percival Tristan says that
he and Lancelot were evenly matched in
power until about six years ago that is
when Lancelot mysteriously disappeared
from the kingdom of benwick when he
returned three years later he seemed
fine as if nothing had happened but
there was one massive change in Lancelot
he had somehow attained a terrifying new
strength and magical power and
lancelot's strength is currently already
on are with the legendary seven deadly
sins from the original manga Tristan
openly admits that lancelot's power is
far beyond his own and so it's time to
talk about the strongest Knight of the
Apocalypse the son of Bonn and Elaine
Lancelot Lancelot is the night of War
according to the prophecy and because he
is half fairy he has the unique ability
to shapeshift Lancelot has actually been
around since like chapter 2 of the
sequel manga but we didn't realize at
first that it was him because all the
way up to chapter 47 he was taking the
form of a talking Fox named sin if you
were a fan of the original Seven Deadly
Sins which I would assume that most of
us are then you know that Lancelot was
first introduced in chapter
346.5 of the original manga that chapter
tells the story of how at the age of 10
Lancelot and his trainer Jericho
disappeared from benwick as a result of
Strange Magic magic that is probably
related to the Lady of the Lake because
spoiler alert nakaba borrows a lot from
Arthurian Legend and in Arthurian Legend
Lancelot spends several years being
raised by the Lady of the Lake as we
learned from Tristan Lancelot went
missing six years ago and he was missing
for three years but then he returned as
if nothing happened except he was
suddenly a lot more powerful and I am
willing to bet that this power-up is
linked to the Lady of the Lake in some
way but let's move on when he finally
reveals his true identity in the Four
Knights of the Apocalypse manga Lancelot
explains to Percival and the others that
he is actually in the service of
meliodas the king of Leones Lancelot is
basically a secret agent working
directly for meliodas and his mission is
to locate all the Knights of the
apocalypse and bring them to leonis
where they will meet the king the more
we learn about Lancelot the more we
realize just how incredibly strong and
skilled away Warrior he is and yet
despite this most people have no idea
who he is they haven't even heard any
rumors about him despite the fact that
he is such a strong Warrior who happens
to only be 16 years of age and that is
something that people would certainly
want to talk about but the reason why
there are no rumors about Lancelot is
because he makes sure that none of the
enemies who face him in battle will ever
live to tell the tale he straight up
eliminates all of his enemies after
defeating them which is pretty ruthless
but it is also incredibly useful in his
line of work after all he is essentially
a secret agent who operates in the
shadows using many different forms and
identities then if people start talking
about him and he becomes famous then he
would no longer be able to carry out his
important missions we know that even as
a 10 year old kid Lancelot had above
average physical strength Superior
reflexes and exceptional combat
capabilities as I mentioned earlier his
power used to be on par with Tristan and
then he disappeared and came back much
stronger along with the ability to
shapeshift lancelot's connection to the
fairy Clan also gives him the ability to
read the minds of his opponents which is
a power known as heart reading this
ability is extremely useful in battle
because it allows Lancelot to anticipate
his opponent's next move and since his
opponents usually don't know anything
about him having a connection to the
fairy Clan lancelot's ability to read
them usually catches them completely off
guard in addition Lancelot is also very
skilled Archer and he uses a bow and
arrow with unbelievable speed and
accuracy his offensive capabilities are
absolutely devastating and we saw this
early on as he was able to instantly
kill doronak one of the Holy Knights of
Camelot with just one punch to the gut
and if that wasn't enough Lancelot has a
magical ability called shining road
which allows him to fire a beam of light
at an opponent this beam will then chase
after its Target and follow it like a
heat-seeking missile until it destroys
it
lancelot's true power becomes apparent
in chapter 79 when he takes on King
Arthur one on one and this is after
Arthur already outclassed Tristan and
after he even managed to gain the upper
hand on meliodas although to be fair
meliodas was being held back by the fact
that he was protecting his out of
control son Lancelot ends up intervening
to stop meliodas from being killed by
Arthur and then he goes toe-to-toe with
Arthur himself Lancelot actually lands
several powerful blows on Arthur causing
Serious injury and forcing Arthur to
activate the power of Chaos in order to
regenerate although I guess technically
the power of chaos activates itself when
it senses that its host is in danger so
Arthur doesn't even have to do anything
consciously chaos instinctively acts to
protect him at this point Arthur
confirms that meliodas at full power is
still stronger than Lancelot but there
is no doubt that Lancelot is the strong
longest of the Four Knights of the
Apocalypse at least for now in fact
meliodas and Tristan seemed hopeful that
even with the power of chaos actively
protecting Arthur Lancelot may still
have a chance to defeat him I mean that
is just an incredible level of
confidence that meliodas and Tristan
have in lancelot's power but before
Lancelot can force a Battle to the death
with Arthur the holy Knights of Camelot
arrive on the scene inside like a flying
monster ship that appears in the sky
above leonis Arthur then warps up to the
ship and the ship disappears before
Lancelot and the others can stop them
but as he departs Arthur declares
all-out war and he vows to hunt down the
Four Knights of the apocalypse and their
allies and to eradicate them all that is
pretty intense and there we have it the
Four Knights of the Apocalypse ranked
from weakest to strongest based on all
the information that we have thus far
all four of them have rare and unique
powers and incredible potential and it
is possible that these rankings might
shift sometime in the near future
personally I was surprised to learn that
Lancelot was already on the level of the
legendary seven deadly sins from the
original manga especially since we know
that he's only a 16 year old kid but
that also makes things more interesting
since Lancelot proves that we won't have
to wait hundreds of chapters for the
Four Knights of the Apocalypse to reach
the level that the seven deadly sins
were at at the end of the original manga
things are moving very quickly in the
sequel and we can expect the action to
intensify now that King Arthur has
declared all-out war against the Four
Knights of the Apocalypse the Four
Knights are now assembled the battle
lines have been drawn and I can't wait
to see what happens next I'm especially
interested to see the other sins return
to the story including of course Bon
Diane and King based on recent events
and clues in the latest chapters we can
expect all of them to appear soon which
is awesome let me know what you guys
think do you agree with my rankings and
if not where would you place the Four
Knights in terms of current strength and
power level where do you think the story
is going to go from here don't forget to
comment down below I always love hearing
from you if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more seven deadly sins
and Four Knights of the Apocalypse
content here on the channel leave a
quick like to help me out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications if you
don't do that you're still gonna miss a
ton of our videos in the future even if
you are subscribed it's just how YouTube
works you can also hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys